Bill Burr comedian baby made headline in
October 2000 and 2000 after controversy
2 000 and 2000 Mike that's 20 20. it was
Brownsville schools man Phil tell me man
but listen right
Colorado he trains Rose named Eunice
yeah
do you love her I love her I love her
too I love all the USC female Fighters
that's why I want my daughter to know
all of that stuff that'd be cool when
she meets a creep like you she could
choke you out
bro I'm gonna say something right you
walked up this [__] drive pointing at
me
laughs
I came over here during rush hour
podcast and I'm grateful that you're
here nothing but a red line the whole
way over here you don't want to drunk
when your kid's around my [__] Lou
Grant with a bottle of whiskey and the
remember that in Mary Tyler Moore Show
she'd have a rough day and she'd come in
and I don't remember the whole show I
can explain it to you yeah if I can
explain it okay
I don't know what that is all right
I don't know I don't know and the second
I started to explain like I don't know
the whole show all right I get it I get
it I believe is that comic add like I
don't even [__] I'm not into it I don't
want to hear it I got it yo show go
ahead continue I remember uh all right
let's talk about old shows then we don't
have to I just was so funny how you
[__] you bailed twice on that Patty
Duke it made me feel like an [__]
like that was the 15th time I [__]
brought it up
sorry no Mary Tyler Moore one of the
great Ensemble [__] casts of all time
I do know she just died recently
uh yeah I mean I was gonna bring up a
more positive story about the show but
yeah it's the second time because if you
Vlog yourself for for being vulnerable
would you stop it like you have some
sort of psychology degree 10 years in
therapy it's so much I've watched
football for 40 years I shouldn't be
somebody's coach
do you remember when they lit up the
puck for a few years on TV yeah that was
you guys you know no but yeah but the
NHL
no no wait
stop timeout timeout the NHL is you guys
too so all the owners had to agree with
that and you all had to be like we gotta
we gotta like expand this thing we
thought we'd funnel money into Canada
and keep it here but you guys took it
over like you tend to do but well
no you're big on the yeah that's just
business dude you're acting like we came
and knocked you on the head you know
what we're about yeah we well wait a
minute oh yeah wait a second
fellow white person not native to this
country how did you guys get this up
here did the Native Americans go oh well
we like these white guys
Jesus Christ
oh I get it your [__] smells like maple
syrup up here
[Applause]
's just another Photoshop
yeah it's a photo shoot people do photo
shoots yeah I know have you ever seen
like a movie poster and you'll see a
movie she's clearly five foot two yet
somehow he's as tall as the super I have
I have yeah that's that's a photo shoot
no thick stuff
look I'm sorry you're just on the web
man
you you took it he took it to this place
I'm not trying to [__] on his website
what is it called again
huh zippityduda.com it's the older guys
Robert Kelly's and all they all call you
Billy Colin calls you Billy but I
[__] Bill I'm just immediately
noticing that I don't know about the
chain if it's if it's thick enough to be
that warm that level of confidence yeah
but it's more of a necklace
you just had you have nine different
positions since you've started this
sentence yeah because I've been training
training with Trevor Whitman oh yeah
with my footwork oh Trevor Whitman oh my
god do you know him no
the deepest couch in sports
entertainment a lot of people think that
uh they're uncomfortable with my uh my
um elevation are you uncomfortable with
it no I just see all of your
insecurities in a giant desk you gush
you gush over your daughter not everyone
gushes did your dad gush over you
uh I mean I was too little yeah no my
dad was my dad actually at work did at
work that's what I learned like oh my
God yeah he really likes us and when he
came home yeah he was cracking the whip
that's your bed mate you're doing your
studies well why not you know who's that
[__] and uh he also had a zillion kids
so I mean yeah really how many siblings
do you have I don't know dude the
internet's too [__] weird to give out
all that information oh you don't even
want to say how many because you're
afraid that it was yeah you're talking
about it is there anybody you can cut
this out I'm honest dude like seriously
yeah no dude I yeah this [__]
lunatics out there okay well off the air
off the air all right
geez
I love how surprised he is well if you
can mention them now absolutely
absolutely crazy people okay yeah no are
you in the people I cannot get
comfortable in this [__] chair this
is just like one of the worst things
it should be like hitting museum is like
the Prototype this is what
this was the awful level of comfort we
went from a log to this and then
eventually they got cushions
it's another guy looking at his phone I
swear to God
through the day Jesus comes back if he
ever does if he's even a real person
like 90 of people are gonna miss it
they're gonna walk right he's gonna be
walking on water and immediately walking
by him and not even I know you were
laughing you were [__] yawning over
here no the mushrooms you're killing me
man I knew it wasn't just weed I was
just like there's no way I'm taking a
hit off of that there's something going
on here mushrooms baby the shrooms I'm
shrooming
[Laughter]
he's shrooming and he's wearing pants
like he went riding a horse today like
side saddle or some [__]
don't be like my wife my wife is like
dick Patrol man don't be like checking
out my [__] tight pants like I love
how you came at me aggressive and now
you're going you got your pain this
Little Panda hands
I love how you attacked My Little Pony
let me just look like you look like a
little Panda I know I was just because
when you took your shirt like a little
adolescent bear
at some point I was going to make a
point here that's why I keep looking at
here and I just realize I'm blocking
myself out of the camera I love that you
have the jib camera for this like it's
an action movie let's let's swoop in at
these two guys sitting in these
unbelievably small chairs I literally
feel like I'm gonna fall under the floor
this is insane you really went all out
with the audience though they got
full-size adult chairs
are these like from the 20s before they
had like horse tranquilizers in our food
when everybody was like five foot one
so your Christian background is is part
of the the show yes and I wanted to talk
to you about Jesus after that well the
only reason why I bring it up is some
people thought maybe you went a little
too far you know as far as what well
they thought that maybe you were being
disrespectful to the Christian religion
I'm telling you you need to Google oh
good lord
be disrespectful or just you you were
just having fun with some of the
crucifixes and stuff like that I don't
even know what I mean we did maybe two
jokes about that yeah exactly don't you
think the Catholic Church went a little
too far
more so than my cartoon all right listen
a couple of jokes I know this is a
morning show you can't bring up all
those crimes you know what they just
sort of kept moving them around you know
like those killer whales at Sea World
after it kills a trainer they'll then
move it up to Seattle they don't give
them their background all right I'm not
totally following it but I don't think I
know what I'm talking about it's a
Morning Show I understand yeah
that kid was missed the graduation and
then then it was a feel-good story feel
good and we want to leave if you want to
feel good about America you watch the
morning shows you don't watch this you
know okay and one was joking earlier if
that kid's story about the graduation
was late night that would have been a
whole different story what do you think
are you still missing we can't find him
all we found was his hat but you watch
in the morning it's great it all worked
out he got his own personal graduation
like I was in such a great mood look how
yellow this couch is it's like